you've again done an excellent job being
very careful in your presentation uh
making sure not to exaggerate or
use hyperbole
but i did want to ask you
um you have personally had a
run-in with
what maybe we're not supposed to call
uh detention or camps or whatever i'm
not i haven't gotten the memo that tells
me what i am supposed to call it um but
uh
what happened
yeah well i look i have and and and i
mean i use that term quite openly i'm
pretty comfortable with it detention is
when you cannot leave so being detained
is what it is so i you won't offend me i
can assure you but um the um the the
scenario here is we i obviously in my
job um i travel a lot because you know a
member of the the government and uh we
travel to canberra which is effectively
our washington i sit in the senate over
there um so it's required a lot of
travel there have been periods where we
haven't but throughout the course of the
last two years um
we have seen a different way of doing it
every time on very early on when we
would leave we would come back from the
australian capital territory which is
where canberra is we would probably
quarantine at home for two weeks and we
got used to doing that then as things
subsided a bit we we didn't at all we
would just return to normal life as i
think has been the case in the united
states crossing boundaries
um
as the days and weeks went on and the
healthcare bureaucracies decided that
you know they would become more
prescriptive with their rules and
requirements these these almost
visa-like arrangements between traveling
between states started to emerge
uh during our last trip which was back
in november
i left the state with one set of rules
and came back to a different set of
rules
what that meant was that by the time i
was coming back i was required as were
all parliamentarians to apply for
the right to return to my home uh
through a specially crafted and i'm sure
very clever system um
through the internet the entry check
system which had been developed here i
was denied twice the ability to come
home
and
you know you fill in the ask the
questions and so on and so forth and
then ultimately um i was told that i
needed to go into a midi hotel um for 14
days uh with no right of review and i i
mean you know that has happened before
but it hasn't happened in any of the
other previous
um yeah you know scenarios when we've
been traveling
uh and of course the thing that really
stuck out in my mind the thing that
started to really um raise concerns
about the rationale for that was the
fact that after 10 minutes of being told
that i got a call from a journalist who
also knew about it uh who knew about all
the details in the same language that
the the email that i'd received telling
me about it um and then i was met by
photographers and media at the airport
in order to document the whole thing and
frankly the exercise is not as bad as it
looks i in fact looked for the officials
to tell them i'm apparently told i need
to go into a midi hotel but those
officials are police officers so
the scene looked like you were being
detained and dragged away which you sort
of were but it wasn't quite as draconian
as that but once again uh the next day
in our local newspaper that was splashed
across the front you know antique
detained you know so on and so forth
then i spent um 14 days there despite
having had a covered test um i think
the day before leaving and then we'll
count them up six during my time in the
hotel
um and no ability to get out and i was
taken to a medi hotel once again metal
fence around the bottom police there
um
you know three meals brought to your
door um
you know during the day with a knock on
the door like you're in you're in a
prison environment
you can't leave to get the the meal more
than three minutes before it's left and
you can't leave it out there longer than
10 minutes for in the reasons of science
presumably who knows why
and you know checks every day on your
mental health and i kept saying well i'm
fine but i'd be better if you'd let me
go home
and yeah all this sort of stuff you know
and so it was a nice hotel in the middle
of the city not far from where i've
worked before but if you can't leave
that environment you are in there so
what's the message that has been sent
i've spent the last six months poking
around the local health bureaucracy who
are the you know the really the ones
that made that decision asking for
documents asking for information asking
them to show us the science that we're
meant to trust
and then fell on the receiving end of
that little trick on the way through and
of course
um the last 24 hours here in australia
have seen
um the world number one tennis player
novak djokovic go through a similar
experience he also is of serbian
extraction so i'm not going to suggest
for a minute there's some sort of
serbian anti-serbian conspiracy in
australia i would only say that in jest
but um the the similarities are
frightening he's currently in a midi
hotel in melbourne um
to the best of my knowledge with no
symptoms of covert
and that really is the question here
where's the science that says
whatever it turns out to be the case
whether he's there's an issue with
vaccination or not or exemptions or not
where's the science that says
allowing him in if he can test
negative even you know despite the fact
that there are a hundred thousand cases
of covert floating around in our
community across the country
where is the science that says that's a
reasonable thing to do and what is the
reality for reputational damage for our
country um when this sort of stuff is
happening i mean we just don't know the
details yet that matters in front of the
courts at the moment but um this
business of taking people and locking
them up against their will as you said
earlier quite rightly it doesn't matter
if it's in a five-star hotel and you're
sitting around a pool if i can't leave
if you can't leave then you're being
detained it's as simple as that and that
is happening too commonly in this
country at the moment
so it sounds to me
[Music]
like both you and mr djokovic
were
imprisoned
to prevent you from transmitting a
disease to others that neither of you
apparently had i think that's about
right i think that's a very very apt
summary here
it does not
i mean things may be different south of
the equator but north of the equator
that doesn't sound like it's logical to
me it just sounds um beyond preposterous
in fact
it's hard to even know what to make of
it and i you know i think you know you
said soft totalitarianism uh i have used
the term surgical totalitarianism
there is something to the idea of
we are being broken in
on accepting certain things that
ourselves from two or three years ago
would have uh balked at in the strongest
possible terms
um
i i'm not sure even what to say about it
except at some level just
people need to listen to the description
of what has happened they need to hear
you not
leaping to conclusions about it not
saying anything beyond what actually
happened just the simple facts of it and
ask themselves
are we being
governed
by rational people in our collective
interest or is something else going on
because
increasingly i don't think any of this
actually squares the with the idea that
people who
are obsessed with our medical well-being
are perhaps a bit carried away i i don't
think you can explain this that way this
looks like something
is uh
taking a kind of power that we never
would have given up absent an emergency
and it doesn't look like it's planning
to give it back
no and we say that all the time here i
mean every day um things seem to slip
again you know we we see this
that story about the northern territory
yesterday um is something that was
unexpected because it felt as though
we'd moved past all of that and as you
say in a temporary environment where
i think the terminology used in this
state is a major emergency has been
declared and has been declared for two
years you would assume that that major
emergency would you know evaporate but
of course we're not seeing that at all
in fact if if anything i think we're
seeing it getting ratcheted up in some
some aspects so
look it doesn't make sense what it is
doing of course is and this is another
entire limb but a societal limb is it's
dividing australians and the anecdotal
evidence from the christmas period is
that it was a
probably was the same in the united
states a sort of a fraught period where
families were fighting amongst
themselves because of whether people
wanted to even congregate in numbers at
all in this state as we speak right now
uh health bureaucrats have dictated that
you cannot have more than 10 people in
your home
for any reason as far as i'm aware um
you know and and businesses can't have
more than 25 percent of their normal
uh customer flow so throughout that new
year period
businesses were just hemorrhaging
hemorrhaging money their hard costs of
rent and electricity they don't change
small businesses are
facing this this critical period
families are facing this critical period
and it doesn't seem to be getting any
better and we are seeing that division
rolling out through this country and i
you know like everybody who's involved
in the public sphere in the public town
hall you know sort of setting i try to
speak to people about it as rationally
as i can and i say
do you think you would understand this
if i was to come back to you in in two
three five years and you know you had an
app on your phone that told you you
couldn't buy another tank of petrol gas
you know
today because we're in the middle of a
climate emergency because
you know in one sense
it is hard to imagine us a time
where this won't continue if we don't
stop it now where social credit as we
see in places like china um isn't you
know at least more persuasive in here
and we were just told this week um that
in south australia there's a meat
shortage um you know i'm sure there's a
rational explanation for that but
you know it also sounds a little bit
like um
you know
we have been hearing out of the world
economic forum we have to cut down on
meat and these sorts of things you know
where does this stop do we end up
becoming a country that is dominated by
the naughty or nice register that sits
on our phone
and are people live enough to it and
will people you know when for example
they go to the bottle shop
to buy you know a cart and a beer and
can't do it because you know they've
already had one this week is that enough
to wake people up
because at the moment i don't think that
those lines of uh of sort of thought
have been joined but i fear they're
coming and i feel we need more people to
speak up
well if i can
say what i think i heard you just say in
different terms it seems to me that
there are
basically two possible systems
you can have a system in which your
bureaucracy
is empowered
to
decide
when your rights apply and when your
your rights don't apply based on
emergencies of which there will be many
in which case
i don't know whether your climate
example is sensible or not but it's
certainly no more preposterous than what
we are seeing now so you know is it
acceptable for
our governments of the west to decide
well the time has come to uh
to eliminate your rights uh over
climate or or
racism or whatever else it's going to do
um
or are we going to have a system
in which
the only
thing the only tool our bureaucrats have
should they wish to relieve us of our
rights is persuasion where they actually
have to convince us that this in fact
does merit that step
and
i think you know those of us who are
paying attention have now seen enough of
this to know that there is only one
right answer to that question a system
in which they have to persuade us
to put aside those rights temporarily
because something necessitates it is the
only tolerable system one in which they
are empowered to decide when we are in
that situation is one that is
automatically going to be abused uh
until we until we uh until we change
[Music]
you